jedes Mal wenn einer seinen Asylantrag
in der Ausländerbehörde einreicht gibt's
zusätzlich einen pflichtvortrag und zwar
durch einen ausgebildeten
klischeehausmeister so dann pass mal auf
Sportfreund bei uns in Deutschland gibt
es Regeln erstens wir lassen unser
Fahrrad nie im Flur stehen zweitens wir
reden während der Fahrt nie mit dem
Busfahrer und am allerwichtigsten wenn
wir hier zum Grillen eingeladen sind und
man ist hier immer irgendwo zum krillen
eingeladen dann bringen wir
Kartoffelsalat mit und zw gen mit zu
viel Mayonnaise los probieren ist aber
vegane Mayonnaise oder ich gebe dir
gleich vegane
Mayonnaise